my son's schedule every day after he
gets off school 3 to 4 he swims 4 to 5
is soccer 5 to 6 is Jiu-Jitsu 6 to 7 is
baseball by the time he comes home he
asked me a question the other night he
says daddy do I have a busy schedule or
just a normal schedule for all kids he
says because when I talk to my friends
they don't have my schedule here's what
I will tell you so what's that you're
bed David I don't care what the Jones's
schedule is I don't care what the
Jackson schedule is this is the B David
schedule even with parenting you can do
everything right and a kid can still
screw up they can still be tempted on
one day they're P off at their daddy and
they walk away and say my girlfriend is
right all you care about is money you
don't love us you could buy me this car
you could buy me the house like the
other person is doing but you are so
cheap I know that moment is coming but
I'm good with it and I'm going to Stand
My Ground because I'm banking by 2530 if
they get through that ugly phase of
hating dad the three phases you got to
go through with your father you idolize
you demonize you humanize